alors quoi de beau bonjour à tous alors
ce dimanche c'est la journée mondiale de
l'orgue
c'est pour ça qu'on est dans une église
accompagnée de Jean-Marc élève organiste
ici à Coignières dans les Yvelines bien
sûr alors quoi de beau ce weekend
[Musique]
ça c'est une note de musique ça c'est un
tuyau je peux taper ça donnera rien du
tout ça c'est les notes les plus basses
[Musique]
et les plus aigus
je crois que je l'entends là on dit que
les claviers sont accouplés
en général et tu peux faire en trois
genre tu mets le pied sur un truc ça
fait les trois
si tu veux merci chef
[Rires]
[Musique]
et le voisinage il se plaint pas ah non
parce que ça ne fait pas de bruit du
vent bon bien sûr si on met à fond la
caisse le voisin seront enchantés
[Musique]
je sais pas faire
et maintenant
terminé il y a plus de vent qui donc là
on peut jouer de la guitare on a planté
les tuyaux il fait toute la largeur
oui il est tout petit donc il faut
abréger ah ouais la largeur par rapport
du sommier au clavier
[Musique]
quand le facteurs quand il accorde Sa
fait
tout à coup on entend un son unique il
dit c'est bon et on passe à la note
d'après merci Jean-Marc et merci aux
amis de l'ordre de Coignières de nous
avoir laissé jouer ce bel instrument
[Musique]